I was at a
loss for words ah ah ah ah
ah ah
yeah I
knew it was coming because the footsteps made my feet and so on So let's
fly with wings
Are you still doing it
?  The direction of the sound source is determined by which ear hears it first. If you
shift upstream, you can see not only the direction but also the height.
Increasing
[music]
AI doesn't feel it, or rather there aren't many places to hide in the first place
ah ah ah I
knew why it flew away
I melted the mess This is Mr. Higuchi's domain Is there a good way to do it?
If I add jagged edges, I wonder if I can disperse the wind noise and reduce the sound
.
And the ears are fluttering and very conspicuous so
Hmm party
I specified that the meaning is not right
Oh
[music] Stick the
oily ears into your face With
this, even if you turn your head, the silhouette will change  Let
's put together the ideas we've come up with so far
Good animals
100 series
I'm glad it's not the strong figure of Mama
Soil Where did the important ear parabola go?
By the way, the skull looks like this. The
ear holes are on the front and go up and down
. Did you use that long neck as it is?